[Musique]
les shadoks sont sur la planète à eau
ils croient que la terre est en dessous
il avait installé un système compliqué
de tuyaux pour pomper l'eau de la
planète et la mettre à sec
[Musique]
les poissons voulons au début je
trouvais ça amusant et venaient les
regarder travailler
loudun comptait commencer à baisser et
de l'autre il y avait une petite planète
qui se formaient ils pompent r comme ça
pendant assez longtemps mais pas le plus
petit bout de terre n'apparaissait si
bien qu'à la fin ils pompaient ils
s'aperçurent enfin qu'il s'était trompé
et qu'il n'y avait pas de terre il ne
restait que les poissons volants qui
étaient pour ainsi dire obligé de nager
à pied sec et qui n'était pas content du
tout il allait revoir les shadoks et en
manger un certain nombre puis ils
exigèrent qu'ils remettent leur planète
là où il l'avait prise et plus vite que
ça
les châteaux encore une fois se remirent
[Musique]